there's been the most
dreadful accident a woman she was
demanding money threatening me i
i had no idea my dogs were losing i
think
they were chasing someone
with me leave the bag
a thousand pounds no i'm calling the
police
landlord stay here don't touch anything
she's coming
the baronet what she's coming
battle stations everyone action
[Music]
baroness
outside that window display
i'm so sorry i can explain that
you're right here we go sorry baroness
um
get her she's the vandal who messed up
the whole
window display so we're dealing with it
all right so she works here
oh no no she was fired yeah i tried to
give these wretches a chance but um
breeding need i say more
so she doesn't work here
sorry i'm not convinced you're sweating
and i can smell you
brilliant thank you you
grubby girl yes jeffrey card
carl
you're hired this address 5am don't be
late
dave
dull you're fired
tasty perfect
why are you speaking i i think you
nicked me
fabrics could give me red like that
where's the beading for the dress
ordered
just waiting on this idiot delivery man
baroness designs stunned with her
reinvention of the a
line with a bias carton higher line that
reshapes the silhouette
in such an audacious fashion the
audience broke into rapturous applause
at first
sight she really is a genius
i'll read that last bit again she really
is a genius
a triumph again
all right how do i look
i know that
show me
how would you have done it
hmm
i think you're something
master of understatement as usual
here's to me
[Music]
dear light
for sure
get her who are you you look
vaguely familiar i look stunning
i don't know about familia darling your
hair is it real
like my ball i like to make an impact
right what was your name
cruella oh
that's quite fabulous and you designed
this you did
actually 1965 collection oh no wonder i
love it it's mine
i fixed it arrested for transport
where are you going
[Music]
[Applause]
oh we need that
well here's hoping there's a plan c
right what's plan c
what warm saying is is there a player
see
get in a big quicker you're a dog
oh didn't know you knew how to drive
oh i don't there's a car
motorcycle comes up it flies into the
middle and starts spinning
spins and it's cruel
buddy don't play with the strange rubber
dog
i don't even know you i'm jasper
pleased to meet you say hello horace
i am not saying hello
come here
[Music]
do
[Music]
touching
[Music]
they say there are five stages of grief
well i'd like to add one more
revenge as we know cruella deville
is pretty villainous in this film we get
to see how
she became the villain we know today
we're on the story is
wholly original in a different time
period being in the late 70s
you have that glint in your eye and what
clean
one of the most fun things to explore is
her creativity she is very good at what
she does
designing i want to make art
and i want to make trouble the character
is so much fun
and so kind of intoxicating once you put
this wild black and white hair and this
incredible makeup and these completely
unique costumes on
you feel like cruella deville the
villains are always kind of the fun ones
i'm starting to remember you have a bit
of an extreme side
you